bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
session d'information locale sur tv fil
78 dans l'actualité de ce 6 janvier
le collège intercommunale philippe de
champaigne et les écoles élémentaires et
maternelles de la verrière évincé du
réseau d'éducation prioritaire à la
rentrée 2015 la ville s'inquiète
mobilisation prévue demain matin à
l'arrachage maire de la commune est
l'invité du jour
les hommages se multiplient depuis la
disparition de l'ancien pilote jean
pierre beltoise décédé lundi à 77 ans
des hommages qui dépasse le monde
automobile
l'elysée parle d'un homme qui aimait son
sport qui voulait faire partager son
enthousiasme est très engagé pour la
sécurité au volant
les soldes d'hiver qui débutent demain
matin dès 8 heures des bonnes affaires
peut être avez vous fait un peu de
repérage les commerçants en tout cas son
prêt vous le verrez dans l'actualité
également les suites du drame survenu le
7 septembre dernier à flins sur seine où
une fillette de 13 ans perdait la vie en
tombant d'un manège l'attraction
n'aurait jamais dû être ouverte au
public
le contrôle technique était périmé
l'exploitant pourrait donc être
poursuivi le juge d'instruction devrait
boucler le dossier avant la fin du mois
le temps de terminer les toutes
dernières expertises nous revenons donc
ce soir sur la disparition de jean
pierre beltoise c'était l'un des plus
grands pilotes français symbole de l'âge
d'or du sport automobile l'un des rares
également à avoir brillé sur deux roues
avant de prendre le volant
il a ensuite passé le reste de sa
carrière à défendre la sécurité routière
et notamment depuis son circuit qu'il a
décidé d'installer à trappes
anthony rech et patrick jacques de
dixmude s'y sont rendus cet après-midi
86 grand prix de formule 1 huit podiums
dont le mythique succès à monaco en 1972
sous une pluie battante pilote à l'aise
partout 11 fois champion de france de
moto 14 participations 24 heures du mans
jean pierre beltoise aime la compétition
par dessus tout et les qualités de
trajectoire jean pierre a été le premier
qui a redonné un certain lustre spa
automobiles français et qui a entraîné
dans la foulée d'abord une
revalorisation du sport automobile qui
était un peu tombé en désuétude de en
france est une réussite qui inspire de
nombreux pilotes comme arnaud jabouille
ou encore prost après sa carrière il a
consacré la suite de sa vie et à la
sécurité des pilotes
développe des stages de prévention
notamment au circuit qui portait son nom
à trappes avec sa méthode conduire juste
qui voulait ça m'intéresse pas du tout
de faire des circuits pour faire plaisir
ce qui m'intéressait terre dit choqué
pour qu'un jour le gouvernement et les
responsables des boîtes 10
mais effectivement avec le système mis
au point par jean pierre beltoise et
conduire juste ont réduit de moitié ou
des deux tiers ou des trois cases
accidents de la route
très proche de son personnel ici à
trappes parce que la plupart des gens
qui ont collaboré avec lui l'ont fait et
le font depuis quasiment l'origine
c'est-à-dire pour la majorité de nos
collaborateurs c'est plus de 20 ans jean
pierre beltoise est décédé à l'âge de 77
ans après deux accidents
cardiovasculaires à dakar
l'entretien de ce journal a à présent
c'est avec alain jacques bonsoir vous
êtes le maire de la verrière demain vous
mobiliser les habitants autour de la
nouvelle carte du réseau d'éducation
prioritaire et les nouveaux critères
d'attribution des aides elle a été
dévoilée cette carte mi-décembre par la
ministre najat vallaud belkacem le
réseau d'éducation prioritaire permet
aux établissements qui sont rattachés de
bénéficier de moyens supplémentaires ce
qui vous gêne à linge âge c'est la
sortie des écoles de votre secteur de ce
réseau qu allez vous perdre
avec ce changement quelles seront les
conséquences pour vous écouter déjà
effectivement on a été un peu surpris à
la fois sur la méthode sur le fond
puisque sur la méthode on a été prévenus
partiquement est d'ailleurs l'annoncé a
été faite le 17 décembre quelques jours
avant les vacances scolaires pour
rentrer en application pour la rentrée
prochaine ces actes eux mans donc avec
peu de temps pour réagir
peu de documents qui nous ont été remis
une incompréhension d'autant que dans le
même temps nous on fait un petit peu on
essaye de faire confiance en général à
l'état et on se demande si on a bien
raison parce que il ya comme une
schizophrénie madame belkacem a été
ministre de la ville et elle tenait les
mêmes discours que monsieur lamy c'est à
dire une cohérence d'intervention un
seul territoire une seule
politique pour la géographie prioritaire
et pour l'éducation prioritaire aux
résultats nous obtenons en même temps
qu'on nous sort de l'éducation
prioritaire nous obtenons gain de cause
sur le la reconnaissance de la ville en
géographie prioritaire comme claire 70%
de la ville et de sa population va être
en géographie prioritaire et dans le
même temps ce qui représente les moyens
c'est à dire les moyens donnés à
l'éducation prioritaire qui est vraiment
la priorité absolue des contrats de
ville on nous retire nos écoles et le
collège de la géographie prioritaire et
on nous propose en échange une
convention qui est loin très loin de
nous satisfaire et quand je dis nous ce
sont nous évidemment élus nous aussi les
parents d'élèves mais aussi les
enseignants des écoles élémentaires
primaire et du collège évidemment du
mesnil-saint-denis et même de la mer du
mesnil-saint-denis que j'ai eu
évidemment et qui n'est pas satisfaite
de la convention en l'état ça fait une
trentaine d'années que les
établissements sur votre secteur faisait
partie de cette zone d'éducation
prioritaire de ce réseau d'éducation
prioritaire c'est aide concrètement
elles sont matériels sont financières ça
se traduit comment à ccc considérable
c'est par exemple dans nos toutes nos
écoles de la verrière élémentaires et
primaires nous avons des effectifs
réduits
c'est moins de 25 enfants par classe
alors que évidemment si nous n'étions
pas angers obligations prioritaires nous
serions à 32,33 donc déjà cédé
conditions d'enseignement c'est après
des décharges pour les directeurs c'est
du temps de coordination c'est des
appuis financiers c'est des incitations
financières pour les enseignants parce
qu'il faut pouvoir recruter stabiliser
les équipes dans les formes et dans des
secteurs qui sont parfois un petit peu
compliqué un peu difficile donc tout
cela est évidemment ne se retrouve pas
dans le dispositif que nous propose
l'état ces dernières années l'état
multiplie relais normes les sig les
dispositifs les appeler rep les rares
aussi par exemple on peut légitiment
cette volonté de simplifier aussi mais
nous on était pour la certification
permet de sortir du dispositif un pas
pour sortir et surtout pour garder de la
cohérence est d'ailleurs tout le monde
reconnaît que c'est incohérent d'avoir
70 % du territoire en géographie
prioritaire est de ne pas avoir les
écoles en fait nous sommes victimes de
quoi nous sommes victimes d'avoir une
originalité
et départementales voire régionales
c'est un collège intercommunale qui
associe une des communes les plus
pauvres des habitants en tout cas les
moins riches du département avec une des
communes plus aisés du département la
force r&d vous parlez de sa bible est
donc finalement tout ça donne des
moyennes qui sont quand on les compare
bien sûr au dessus des moyennes qu'on
peut avoir aux mureaux à trappes
ceci dit j'ai posé la question à
l'inspecteur départemental pour lui dire
mais notre population n'a pas changé à
la verrière les enfants sont les mêmes
les gens sont même peut-être un peu plus
pauvres qu'ils ne l'étaient il ya deux
ans trois ans les conditions
d'apprentissage sont les mêmes
rien n'a changé à la verrière et
résultat nos enfants nos collégiens nos
enfants d'âge maternel et élémentaire
n'auraient plus les mêmes moyens que les
voisins de trappes pour que les voisins
mais quelle reprise n'a été apportée
lorsque vous l'avez fait remarquer
est-ce que vous avez bon espoir en tout
cas il y aura mobilisation demain dès
8h30 devant les écoles rassemblement
aussi devant la mairie blocage les accès
de la ville ensuite c'est le programme
qui était qui a été établie vous avez
des recours il ya des leviers
il ya aussi grève des enseignants du
collège tous les enseignants du collège
sont en grève jeudi
il ya des écoles de la verrière qui sont
en grève il ya des mouvements de
d'enseignants qui vont avoir lieu
pendant la semaine
l'inspecteur nous a proposé de nous
revoir en début de semaine prochaine
nous savons que sur la région parisienne
il n'y a pas que la verrière qui est
concerné nous espérons faire reculer
effectivement le gouvernement si on ne
nous accorde pas la belle zep mais au
moins qu'on nous accorde les mêmes
moyens
il n'y a pas de raison nos enfants les
mêmes difficultés quatre appuis a aucune
raison que nous n'ayons pas les mêmes
moyens nous serons très fermes et je
vous donne vraiment mon assurance en
tant que maire que nous ne laisserons
pas cette affaire ici la perte des
moyens avec la sortie du réseau
d'éducation prioritaire c'est encore une
mauvaise nouvelle on va dire pour pour
la verrière parce que vous avez parlé
des globalement de des pertes de moyens
venant de l'état les problèmes et de
dotation évoqué ce sujet à présent on va
juste écouter un micro trottoir est ce
que les habitants sont inquiets
actuellement aujourd'hui pour leur
quotidien avec la perte des moyens qui
sont attribués à leur commune oui
beaucoup puisque étant au cfaa de la
fida qui se trouve juste derrière la
gare s'y perd ses subventions pour la
région c'est vrai que et risquent de
fermer donc ce serait ce sera mauvais
pour pas mal de personnes
et à propos des gens qui ont leurs
enfants dans les écoles franchement
s'est inquiété m c'est inquiétant c'est
sûr on a besoin de moyens mais
heureusement on les a pas et il est à ne
fait rien pour moi j'ai pas d'enfant
petit mais bon je pense aux gens qui ont
des enfants petit c'est être un problème
oui ça cette heure du coup il faudrait
faire une des manifestations et sort
deux pas de rêver un peu l'état pour
qu'il nous aide parce que déjà je trouve
qu'ils nous aident pas à vraiment
beaucoup et la saaq qu'il faut faire des
manifestations et on arrive demain à la
verrière en tout cas fait appel a été
entendu mais plus globalement même au
delà de l'éducation
c'est vrai qu'il ya des craintes est ce
qu'aujourd'hui à la verrière vous en
tant que maire vous êtes inquiet sur les
services qui sont proposés sur sur les
hausses d'impôts éventuel forcément
différemment heureusement on a une
gestion rigoureuse pendant toutes les
dernières années ce qui fait que la
verrière n'a pas de dettes n'a pas
d'emprunt donc ça nous donne un petit
délai
néanmoins c'est la première fois qu'on
vote un budget de la ville en diminution
par rapport au budget de l'année
précédente alors que bien évidemment les
frais généraux augmente nous nous avons
les l'inflation etc
donc il faut aujourd'hui faire face à
une diminution de moyens et en même
temps à une augmentation de nos
responsabilités et une augmentation des
attentes des habitants parce que les
habitants aujourd'hui moins aidées par
l'état - et des deux mains par le
conseil général ou le conseil régional
se tourner vers leur mère et dise
monsieur le maire je commande des mois
et des mois sur les aspects de la vie
quotidienne et des mois pour payer le
chauffage et des mois face à mes loyers
qui augmentent les bons salaires qui
n'augmentent pas et des mois pour les
transports et des mois pour la formation
et des mois pour la santé et des mois
pour l'éducation existe envers le maire
économies dans ses comptes dans ce
contexte là et avec les attentes des
habitants vous nous dites pour la
première fois le budget à la verrière
est en diminution
d'ailleurs il est combien le budget sur
votre premier environ 10 millions un peu
en dessous de 10 me livrer en dessous
des millions ils étaient 2 combien
l'année
il était le budget a baissé de quelques
dizaines de milliers d'euros
et au final comment vous faites des
économies
écoutez ça ça ça pousse évidemment à
devoir regarder poste par poste de
dépense par des pensées a commencé à
faire des choix
nous avons commencé à faire des choix
qui sont pas agréables à faire mais par
exemple nous donnions un livre à chaque
enfant moment de noël nous avons
supprimé nous avions une classe de neige
nous l'avons supprimé nous avions des
actions de cette nature sur lequel
aujourd'hui nous essayons nous
reconcentrer pour sur l'essentiel en
laissant quelques fois des choses
importantes
un dernier sujet avant de vous laisser
partir de reprendre le cours de ce
journal vous avez aussi fait face et
quelques temps un trouble de la
tranquillité publique sur la verrière
c'est comme ça qu'on n'en parle il ya eu
des mobilisations de la population de la
gare du quartier d'orly parc peut faire
un point sur cette situation aujourd'hui
la tranquillité est revenu sur ces
quartiers là dans la verrière coudes et
on s'est pas une question qui se
traitent en quelques jours dans quelques
semaines ça se traite sur la durée j'ai
le sentiment des retours que j'ai de la
part de la population mais aussi des
commerçants qui était très concerné que
la situation s'est un peu améliorée
on en est pas encore au bout on continue
d'être attentif vigilant et de renforcer
encore nos moyens on travaille à un
renforcement de la police municipale lui
cherche à recruter c'est difficile
aujourd'hui de recruter ses dépenses
aussi supplémentaire donc il faut
prendre ailleurs
donc voilà tous tous les dispositifs se
met en place une en tout cas des fêtes
de noël et des vacances ils se sont bien
passées tranquillement et donc un retour
pour l'instant satisfaisant mais on
n'est jamais à l'abri de nouveaux
incidents de nouveaux problèmes sur
notre ville comme ailleurs la verrière
n'est pas la seule commune concernée
évidemment merci à l'arrachage rappelle
donc cette mobilisation demain contre
cette nouvelle carte du réseau
d'éducation prioritaire ou en tout cas
pour continuer à obtenir des moyens pour
les établissements pour les écoles sur
la ville de la verrière ce sera dès 8h30
le matin merci à vous merci
demain c'est l'ouverture des soldes
d'hiver les consommateurs les attendent
avec impatience pour refaire leur
garde-robe parfois eric effectué aussi
des achats coûteux du côté des magasins
et des commerçants on s'active tout doit
être prêt pour le jour j reportage
florane parfait williams elle depuis les
clayes-sous-bois dans un centre
commercial
inutile de chercher en rayon les -20 -40
-50% tant espéré par les acheteurs à j -
1 commerçants et vendeurs prépare les
étiquettes et leurs stocks en toute
discrétion de l'aide on peut tous les
produits enfin qu'ils sont en cours de
préparation pour cela c'est quasiment
fait prêt donc ils vont arriver en fait
dans les rayons ce soir on va travailler
très tard dans cette boutique de linge
de maison haut de gamme 5000 produits
doivent être réétiqueter il faut de la
main d'oeuvre en plus moi par exemple
d'habitude je travaille pas enfin dans
le magasin on a une jeune fille qui
travaille aussi
d'ailleurs nous donc qui est aussi
étudiante en école de commerce qui
viennent nous aider et donner ma forte
pour la préparation des produits qui
font rire tous les produits faire une
étiquette qui soit adaptée à la couleur
à la référence et qui indique donc les
trois niveaux de prix selon les magasins
l'organisation est plus ou moins
fastidieuse mais incontournable pour le
prêt-à-porter les seuls deux peuvent
représenter jusqu'à 30% de ventes en
plus sur la période
aujourd'hui c'est la dernière journée on
peut un peu souffler avant demain et
tout les mois qui arrivent on s'arrange
que tout soit bien nickel dans magasin
pour tous soit rangé pour pouvoir ce
soir étiqueté au plus vite et pouvoir
pouvoir avoir des promotions rapidement
qui demande tout soit prêt pour les
clients quand ils arrivent cette année
les soldes seront plus longues six
semaines au lieu de cinq habituellement
auparavant les commerçants bénéficié de
deux semaines de soldes flottantes
cette mesure relative à la loi elle
émeut de 2008 a été supprimé depuis cet
été le seul flottant c'est un petit peu
compliqué même pour la clientèle lançant
ce alors y aller seul et ce faisant les
opérations commerciales cia beaucoup de
choses voilà ça va pas enlever le ca va
pas enlever en fait deux
deux périodes de réduction pour la
clientèle et laurence à me concentrer
une semaine de soldes en plus c'est
cette fois plus de chances de faire de
bonnes affaires pour les soldes a dit le
centre commercial wendy sean offre 10%
de réduction en plus demain de 8 heures
à 10 heures
deuxième volet de notre rétrospective
2014 à présent toujours préparé par
catherine zola tôt que faut-il retenir
de l'actualité locale des mois de mars
et le mois d'avril également nous
poursuivons notre rétrospective avec une
manifestation plusieurs centaines
d'étudiants-infirmiers défilent à paris
en ce 3 mars il s'oppose au boycott des
cliniques qui refuse de les accueillir
en stage c'est notamment ce que
déplorent les élèves de l'institut de
formation en soins infirmiers de la
verrière un centre unique en france
inauguré à saint germain en laye
l'institut en santé génésique
depuis le début du mois de janvier une
vingtaine de bénévoles y accueille des
femmes victimes de violences
elles peuvent être amenées par des
médecins ou tout simplement venir
d'elle-même en poussant la porte des
professionnels ont été formés et
coordonnée pour mieux leur venir en aide
le solar decathlon la grande compétition
mondiale en vue de construire la maison
la plus écologique s'est tenue à
versailles à l'été 2014 mais dès le mois
de mars
le parrain de l'édition était connue le
navigateur michel desjoyeaux un marin
depuis longtemps concerné par le devenir
de la planète
le mois de mars une large page consacrée
aux élections municipales si certains
maires ont été réélus c'est le cas
montigny puis en cours et l'encours
trappe aux magny les hameaux ou encore
la verrière il y à du changement à la
tête de la casse qui la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines n'a jamais été
à droite et c'est dorénavant le cas
depuis le deuxième tour des municipales
et 25 sièges pour la droite 23 pour la
gauche
autre changement cette fois voisins le
bretonneux avec seulement 15 voix
d'écart la liste divers droite mené par
alexandra rosetti remporte la ville
devant le maire sortant alexis biette
élus pourtant depuis 95
alexandra rosicky et l ancienne première
maire-adjointe alexis piette
elle avait quitté la majorité en octobre
2013 pour monter sa propre liste georges
mougeot maire divers gauche de maurepas
depuis 89 avait annoncé qu'il ne se
représenterait pas
la bataille pour lui succéder a été rude
fait de rebondir
monde politique à droite comme à gauche
avec 49 25 % des voix l'ump grégory
arrestier 31 ans a remporté à la
surprise générale le second tour des
élections municipales
il a devancé le favori michel chappe à
37 43 % et le candidat socialiste
ismaila vannes 13,34 pour son attrape un
promu benoît hamon député de la
circonscription de trappes elancourt qui
vient d'être élu sur la liste de guy
malandain va quitter son ministère de
l'économie sociale et solidaire pour
intégrer le ministère de l'éducation
temps scolaire à venir financer des
universités autant de questions qui lui
seront posées nationalement comme sur le
territoire et quittera le ministère à la
fin de l'été juste avant la rentrée
scolaire
des élus qui arrive est d'autres qui
s'en vont alain schmitz quitte la
présidence du conseil général
une présidence marquée par des signes
d'ouverture c'est l'image qu'on gardera
andré sylvestre le président des élus de
gauche au conseil général
un départ officialisé le 10 avril et dès
le lendemain le 11
les conseillers généraux ont élu un
nouveau président alain smith donc
partie la tribune et laissé libre pour
l'ump pierre bédier réélu président du
conseil général des yvelines un fauteuil
qu'il retrouve après l'avoir perdue en
2009 à l'issue d'affaires judiciaires
alain schmitz qui dont la présidence
pour redevenir simple conseiller général
un arrangement entre amis condamne les
élus de l'opposition
et puis autre addiction cette fois la
tête de la casse qui michèle louvier élu
sans surprise président de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est le premier président de droite de
l'agglomération le maire de montigny le
bretonneux dix mesures est la
responsabilité de la tâche et après 2014
quelles sont vos bonnes résolutions
comme tout au long de la semaine vous
avez la parole je serai santé vont
profiter de mes petits enfants c'est
tout ce que je demande à faire plaisir
aux autres j'essaye de le faire et puis
ben voila quoi faire plaisir aux autres
je suis comédien avoir un rôle travers
d'une bonne santé déjà beaucoup de
bonheur des enfants et
mais résolution mois plus de sport
affirmé étude validée le concours
d'avocat et puis continuer comme ça il
posé ma femme aussi notamment
c'est aujourd'hui l'épiphanie la
dégustation de la galette des rois a
commencé pour l'occasion nous sommes
allés assister à un cours de cuisine à
plaisir mélanie poker du lait des oeufs
de la farine du beurre ou encore de la
poudre d'amandes
c'est parti pour deux heures d'atelier
on rajoute le même poids le sucre glace
les apprentis pâtissiers sont venus se
mesurer à la galette des rois la pâte
feuilletée c'est avant tout une question
de patience
deux minutes de travail pour trois
heures de repos et tout cela à quatre
reprises or mais un petit peu de faire
une sur plan de travail
voilà c'est surtout pour que la pâte ne
colle pas donc à la table c'est vrai que
la pâte feuilletée c'est un peu un
mystère donc à savoir la faire soi même
apporté la galette à ses amis en disant
ben voila j'ai fait de mes mains c'est
ces sympathiques
c'est très simple et c'est s'est passé
pas fatiguant c'est pas ça représente
pas un monde comme comme on peut le
monde peut le croire ou comme on peut
l'entendre c'est surtout nettement
meilleur que achetés tout faits en
subventions geler ou auprès après à
cuire un supermarché réputé assez grasse
et consistante la galette arrive
quelques jours après les fêtes de noël
pas toujours facile d'en profiter au
maximum
ce que je veux montrer c'est comme peut
continuer à manger bon même après les
fêtes sans que ça soit lourd parce que
j'ai pris une recette ou même moins de
beurs que traditionnellement dans la
galette on était à plus de beurre que de
farine pendant des années maintenant on
met moins de beurs que de farid donc ça
donne une galette plus légère une fois
cuite est bien dorée il ne reste plus qu
elle a dégusté c'est la fin de ce
journal on se retrouve demain 18h
toujours directe pour une nouvelle
édition n'oubliez pas sur notre site
internet que vous retrouvez ses
précédents les précédents journaux et
puis l'ensemble de nos reportages
soirée